>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Hi everybody.
If you've just arrived, welcome
to the Mystery and Fiction Tent.
My name is Maureen Corrigan.
I am a regular reviewer
for the Washington Post
and the book critic
for Fresh Air on NPR.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Thank you.
The Washington Post has been a
regular sponsor of the book festival
since its inception 10
years ago and I'm happy
to say I think I've been here
every year through all kinds
of weather including this
kind of weather for 10 years.
I am so thrilled to
be able to introduce
to you a writer I greatly
admire, Scott Spencer.
I first became a fan of Scott
Spencer's when I read Endless Love
which still stands as one
of the most elegantly erotic
novels I've ever read.
So I highly recommend it to you.
I also had the pleasure of reviewing
for Fresh Air, A Ship Made of Paper
and both Endless Love and A Ship
Made of Paper were nominated
for the National Book Award.
Here's an inside story
about Fresh Air.
Terry Gross and I sometimes
tussle over authors.
If she is interviewing an author
I usually don't get to review
that author and vise versa and
there are certain authors we always
tussle over.
And she won with Scott
Spencer 'cause it's her show.
So she got to interview
him for Man in the Woods
which is his wonderful new
novel and what could I do?
But I'm thrilled to
say that at least I get
to introduce him to you today.
So without further
ado Scott Spencer.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much, Maureen.
So you realize every time you review
one of my books it gets nominated
for the National Book Award
so I'm counting on you now.
Excuse me.
I'm gonna talk a little bit about
the one thing I know something
about which is writing a novel,
about writing in general,
and I hope that there's time.
I'm gonna make sure
there is time for me
to hear what you guys
are thinking about.
Maybe we can even in this sort
of spacious environment get
some kind of conversation going.
I think there are microphones here.
You know, there's a cliche that
writing teachers tell their students
and I think it's a cliche that goes,
you know, straight to the heart
of what people think about writing
and that is write what you know.
And I've taught in, I've taught
in graduate writing programs.
I've taught in undergraduate
writing programs.
I've taught new writers as different
as, you know, very well healed kids
at Williams College up in
Massachusetts to prisoners
in maximum security prisons.
And they all have been
told write what you know.
And it's not the worst
advice you can have
because you have to start somewhere.
You have to go somewhere
for your material
and minding your own biography,
and minding your own travels,
and minding your own life
is a decent place to start.
But after having written 10 novels
I realize that there is a lot
of writing that I believe in much
more than write what you know
and that is write what
you don't know.
And it's, you know, it was
John Gardner the late novelist
in his book, I think it's called On
Moral Fiction described the novel
and the story as a kind of moral
laboratory where you test hypothesis
of human behavior and figure
out what would happen,
what is a good thing to happen,
what is the good/bad outcome,
how do people behave under stress,
what binds us together,
what pulls us apart.
And that laboratory, I
mean it's a laboratory.
It's different from a
scientific laboratory.
I mean, if you're working for
General Mills you have a job.
You have to make a little piece
of rice crunchy if you put milk
on it and that's your job.
But what the laboratory work of
a novel is more like pure science
where you're just going
in for the investigation
and you don't really have a vested
interest in what the outcome is.
So I do believe in write
what you don't know.
And I'll actually refine that
a little bit and I'll say,
write what disturbs you,
write what confuses you,
and really write what
scares you half to death
and I've written a
lot, really a lot.
It's what I mainly do.
And sometimes it's all I do.
I've written journalism.
I've written reviews, travel
pieces, investigation and each time,
each time I get one these jobs, each
time I get one of these assignments
or get myself one of
these assignments,
it's been like going
to night school for me.
And it's been like
graduate school really.
I mean, I had one assignment
from Rolling Stone to do a piece
about the crooked financier
Marc Rich.
I had no idea who he was.
No idea who he was but sort
of plunged in and found out,
got another job to write about
another Mark, Mark Knopfler.
You know the guitarist whose band
was Dire Straits and who happens
to be, I found out,
just about the living,
the greatest living
guitar player around.
I got another job investigating this
Christian filmmaker who made this
like the Left Behind series
and found out all about that.
But the real Journey without
Maps, that's actually a title
of one of my heroes' books.
That's a Graham Greene book
about his life as a traveler.
But that real journey
without map, the real voyages
of discovery have been novels and,
you know, I've written 10 of them.
And as a writer of 10 novels
I often get to question,
does it get easier as you go along?
And what I always forget to
say is if it does get easier
as I go along then that means
I'm not doing a very good job.
I mean, I like-- actually Joyce
Carol Oates had a great answer
to that question once.
They asked her, you
know, if with the passing
of time does writing
novels get easier
and she said nothing gets
easier with the passing
of time including the
passing of time.
You know, in my 10 novels, I've
imagined or tried to imagine my way
into predicaments that
might not seem very far
from my so-called life because,
you know, writers are like magpies.
If we see something, we just pick
it up and bring it back to our nests
and see how we can use it.
I mean, like I've written
about fatherhood.
Fatherhood is something that's
always been interesting to me.
I was very close to my
father so I'm his son.
I know it from that perspective
and I'm a father with two kids.
But writing about that really
wouldn't take me very deep
into the unknown.
So what I did was write a book
called The Rich Man's Table trying
to imagine my way into what it would
be like if I were Bob Dylan's son
and he refused to recognize me.
And then in another novel, Waking
the Dead, I wanted to write
about my home in Chicago
but rather than just kind
of recapitulate my own experience
there, I wrote it from the point
of view of an on-the-make
politician who's making his way
through Chicago machine politics.
In Endless Love, I sort of
remembering my first real girlfriend
but then I was wondering what
it would have been like if
when her father said I
should stop seeing her
if I burn their house down.
And as used to people-- as used
to reading novels as people are
because we've been
reading novels as a culture
for a couple hundred of years more.
I can't tell you how many people.
>> Even people who kind of know
me think that I possibly did
that because you do plunge yourself
into this alternate reality.
This what-if, so much, and part of
doing your job is to make it seem
as if it were something
that really happened.
You know, like in A Ship Made
of Paper I set that in this town
that I call Leyden, New
York and it's a town
that I've used quite a few times.
And I suppose I could write
a novel about my life there.
It's not completely without
interest, about my poker game
and my tennis and where I shop and.
But I thought it might be more
interesting if I imagine my way
into what it would be like being
an African-American person living
in this sort of slightly
precious upstate New York town.
Now, just to detour for a second,
I wanna talk about this fictitious
little town called Leyden,
New York because I've used it a
few times and I'm using it again
in the book I'm working
on right now and it's
in very much in Man
in the Woods too.
And I partly am writing about
this town because I've been living
in a town like that for 25 years.
It's longer than I've lived
any place else in my life
and I'm still very, very, and I
think of myself as a big city guy
and I can't believe that I've
actually spent the majority
of my life in a little town.
So I'm very surprised of that.
But I see that when you do
live in a town like that
that you do have a chance of seeing
a microcosmic version of the world.
And unlike big cities where people
understandably guard their privacy,
there is not that much
sense of privacy.
There's not the same kind of a
sense of privacy in a small town.
So you get to hear
people's stories and you get
to watch people's lives progress in,
you know, like an ongoing soap opera
with very easy access, excuse me,
with every easy access
to their lives.
So now onto Man in
the Woods which is
yet another book set in this Leyden.
And I thought, I thought it was
going to be when I started off
with fairly tight and
efficient book.
But, you know, you
always have to think that.
You have to tell yourself this.
In order to begin you have
to tell yourself it's going
to be a little simpler than
it's ever really going to be.
But like every other book that I've
written, it meant going on many,
many voyages of discovery and
many, many reconnaissance missions
and there is an awful lot of writing
about what I do not, did not know.
Well and here are a couple of the
things that I had to find out.
One of the things I had to find out
in this book is what is the external
and internal life of
a carpenter, you know,
John Updike always talked about.
It's one of the hardest
things for novelists to do
because we're so strapped
to our desk.
Yeah, I'm a little nervous
so they're circling the tent.
Anyways John Updike always
had trouble finding jobs
for his characters.
I mean, but I knew that my
character was a carpenter.
And so one of the things
that I needed to know
and I don't mean know just in
this kind of term paper way.
But I mean know in that visceral,
deep way that you have to get
to in order to be able to write.
And I needed to know what does
it feels like to love wood.
What do you smell like?
What does your food taste like?
What does it feel to be that
person who knows wood as well
as a dermatologist knows skin or as
an accountant knows the tax code?
And then I needed to know for
this character, Paul Phillips,
what does it feel like
to be self-sufficient.
What does it feel like to be able
to fix things and to make things
and to just do it for yourself,
to not have to depend on society
and in all the networks
of health that we have
and to need basically
nothing for modern life?
Nothing that modern life has to
offer is really of interest to you.
Then further on in the book I
needed to know what it feels
like when you're getting
ready to kill yourself
and especially if you're a bookie.
Oh yeah, and you have to
live in Los Angeles too
and so this is what I've found out.
I'm just gonna read you a
quick little section here.
And this bookie's name is Tom Butler
and he's reached the
end of his rope.
Using his forearm, Tom Butler
pushes the dishes of dried toast
and the unfinished cups of
coffee and the sour winds
of half grapefruit in
its snug little bowl
over to the far side
of his kitchen table.
Using a paper towel, he dries the
area and places 50 sleeping pills
and his notebook in front of him.
He creaks back in the wooden chair
and folds his arms over his chest.
He's in his underwear and his
Hawaiian shirt is unbuttoned.
This bottle of pills,
this blue spiral notebook,
they are all that is left
of the kingdom of his life.
Even the dishes and cups have
receded into the darkness.
The clock ticking on
the wall is invisible.
The exhaust fan over the
cook stove is running just
in case it takes them a
while to find his body.
As for the rest of his house it
may as well have ceased to exist.
The bed, the sofa, the TV,
the Bowflex, the free weights,
the safe in the wall and the world
beyond these walls, the houses,
the stunned palm trees, the pale
yellow sky, the pianist, the gamers,
the oohs and the ahs, the favorites,
the long shots, the spreads,
the people, and the money, the money
that is owed and the money they owe,
a dream, a dream, a
dream you can't remember.
[ Silence ]
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
The other thing that I needed to
and probably the most important
and the most difficult
voyage of discovery
in writing what I didn't know in
this novel is it was actually easier
to imagine my way into wanting to
kill yourself than it was to do this
and that is, what does it
feel like to kill someone.
You know, there's a
lot of death in novels.
But I wanted to go
where, this sounds vain,
but I wanted to go
where Dostoevsky went.
And somehow make it new.
And I wanted this character
who took a life.
I wanted him to feel the way
I would feel and actually,
I'm the best person to do
that because nobody
knows but me, I suppose.
I'm just gonna read one more
short section to give you a sense.
And this is the man thinking
who has done the killing.
Could it really be that simple?
Could a human being be removed from
the ranks of the living with little
or no fuss and no consequences?
What about his house?
What about his belongings?
Was there no one out
there to come forward
and say hey, where is my husband?
Where is my father?
Where is my lover?
Where is the man who worked for me?
Where is the guy at the next desk?
Where is my buddy I went to
the track with every July
or played cards with or jogged with?
Where is that grumpy bastard
with the good looking brown dog?
Where is my tenant?
Where is my next door neighbor?
Was no one curious?
Was no one making a stink?
Wasn't there anyone
wanting an answer?
Could a man really be
plucked from the body of life
like a little splinter and just blow
away and leave no trace of himself?
But he has left a trace in Paul
and here he is carrying
a black garbage bag
into what he has already placed
some broken Coors bottles
and empty bleach container
with crumpled cigarette packs
and a waterlogged paper paperback
edition of Bonjour Tristesse
with his animal companion trotting
a few feet in front of him.
He's walking Shep the dog
and cleaning the country road
over the winter's debris
that spring has exposed.
And as he does he hopes to remove
the toxins in his bloodstream
through the dialysis of good deeds.
[ Applause ]
>> Now, one last-- final-- one
final thing about the characters
in this book and that's,
I have a dog character
in this book named Shep.
He is taking that walk with that
guy as he's cleaning up the road
to swish his conscience and
Shep is the closest thing
to nonfiction in this book.
And because Shep is my dog.
And I have a dog named Shep
and I thought, you know,
I feel about my dog the way
everyone feels about their dog.
And so I wanted to put him in my
book and I thought that would be,
that would be at least
something that I knew going in.
But even there, even there I
realized I didn't know as much
as I thought I did about my own dog.
You know, there was a piece long
time ago, at least 10 years ago,
in the Atlantic Monthly and I guess
these old magazines they have this
really adorable looking
dog on the cover.
And the headline says,
your dog doesn't love you
and your dog is seeing other people.
I don't know what it said.
And basically, his thesis was
that all these adorable things
that dogs do from, you know,
panting if they key you
and all the loyalty is basically
because you're their source of food.
And I thought to myself,
yeah good, good.
Good for the dog.
I don't want that kind
of relationship
where somebody is just sort
of slavishly devoted to me.
And I sort of remembered that piece
and remembered my reaction to it
or against it when I was
portraying Shep in this novel.
And then I realized that Shep
really cares about three things,
protein, comfort, and safety.
And since I am giving him plenty
of all those things I'm
like aces with Shep.
And so Shep actually at that point
became a much more interesting
character to me because he
was no longer just, you know,
he wasn't my dog anymore.
He was somebody who I was having to
imagine my way into the way I had
to imagine my way into Tom Butler
as he is going to commit suicide.
The way I had to imagine
myself into Paul Phillips
when he kills a man
with his bare hands.
Alright. I'm gonna stop
just almost mid thought
in case somebody has
something they wanna ask
because I certainly have
like six more minutes.
[ Pause ]
>> I'd like to ask you
when you get an idea
for a book, how does that happen?
Are you having coffee or
playing poker or are you doing--
and what happens when you
decide ah, that's the next one?
>> That's a great question.
I find that there are two lucky
places for me to have my ideas
and one is listening
to music, live music.
Somehow I don't know what it is.
It just puts me into a
nice little state of mind
where things occur to me.
And the other time
is when I'm driving.
And one of the ways I know that it's
a good idea is if I don't forget it.
And I don't write it
down immediately
because I'm gonna give myself
that chance to forget it
because if this is an
idea I'm really gonna use,
it's something I'm gonna live
with for like three years.
I wanna make sure it's
the real thing.
So I let my memory or lack of
memory kick the tires on it,
you know, before I hop in.
And the other thing is that, you
know, people can have a lot of ideas
but not every idea sort of triggers
that writing thing inside you.
And so I've had what seems
to me like a pretty good idea
or a good notion, or a good
setup, or interesting character
and I'm just gonna assume
in some sort of spiritually,
they've gone on to somebody else
'cause I wasn't the right person
for them.
>> Hi. I'm a big fan of
Endless Love, the book.
The movie not so much and I'm a
movie lover so that's saying a lot.
>> Yeah. But we're making it.
>> Really?
>> That's what they say.
>> I hope you have
more clap this time
because you're obviously pretty
young when they did it last time.
>> Yeah. But believe or
not I am less clapped.
[ Laughter ]
>> Because the business had
become all that more corporate
and distant but go ahead.
>> Oh, I am sorry to hear that.
But your character, it's so much
like Gatsby observing his love
or in Marjorie Morningstar, the
way she is observed it resonated
with me the same way
and I'm wondering
if it was difficult especially
because you were so much earlier
on your career to see the
movie go such a different way
where the inner life
is so secondary.
That's the first part of my question
and the second part is how do
you pitch your book where it's
about the person who's doing the
observing more than the love object?
>> You mean pitch a book
to a publisher or somebody?
>> Yes.
>> Well, I didn't, you know,
if I went in to pitch that book
to a publisher, they would
look at me and say, hey,
how did you get my number?
>> Exactly.
>> I mean and not because, not
because of the book necessary but,
you know, there is no reason
for a publisher to listen to me.
I mean, that book was
very, very successful.
I'll probably never have a book
that was so universally accepted
or successful as that but I
sold that for 10,000 dollars
and I was thrilled that
I got that much for it.
So I didn't pitch this book.
I wrote the whole thing
out and then gave it
to somebody simply
to publish this, so.
But, you know, as to my
feeling about the movie,
it sort of connected to my
answer to the first one.
I mean, I had no money.
I had a kid that was, you
know, three months old
and I was pretty happy to get paid
and buy a house in the country.
I didn't realize that the movie was
going to be some sort of like icon
of bad movie making
as it has become.
And I'm not trying so say, you know,
actually I remained
very good friends
with the screenwriter of that move.
This woman name Judith Rascoe
who has written all kinds
of wonderful movies and art
films and mainstream films
and she sent me this thing
that there's some sort
of like reevaluation of the Franco
Zeffirelli version of Endless Love
and kinda say that it's like a
Douglas Sirk film or something.
But I didn't care for it.
The point of the movie was almost
the opposite of what I was going
for in the novel which is sort of a
celebration of that sort of insane,
heedless teenage love
and I think the tag line
on the movie poster was the
love that every parent fears,
and so that's not going to the
direction I was thinking about.
>> Thank you.
[ Pause ]
>> Okay. I think--
>> One more question, real quick.
>> So, yeah, we have
one more minute.
Please go ahead.
>> How did you get pass the
people that dissuaded you
from ever becoming an author?
Obviously you're--
>> Well, 'cause they didn't
have another suggestion for me.
>> No alternatives.
>> I mean, you know, in my family
making money wasn't that important.
My father worked in a factory so,
you know, the idea that, you know,
I was gonna starve to death
or, it didn't hang over me
like a sword the way it would
have if my father was a doctor
or a lawyer and I felt that
I had to maintain that sort
of upper middle class lifestyle.
So I didn't really, I mean all
that was standing between me
and becoming an author
was learning how to do it.
Okay. Well, thanks for coming out.
It's great to see you all.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.